follow your flow if you're not sure what
to do next in your life if you don't
know what to study if you don't know
where to take your business the best
advice that I can give you right now is
to follow your flow find the things that
excite you that interest you find the
things that make you come alive and go
do that even if it doesn't make any
sense right now this video comes as a
response to a question I got from my
youtube viewers love you guys Tania who
wrote in to say I've always been a
commerce student and dreamed of becoming
a business woman but BS and Media
Studies is a great field of work and
artistic I love to write stories poetry
and so on I'm confused I don't even know
exactly where these both degrees will
take me if you could only tell me what
is exactly in these degrees to work on
Tanya this is a great question and and I
really feel for you and I think
everybody at some point in their life
goes through this period where they're
trying to figure out what do I do with
my life you know am i studying the wrong
thing am I in the wrong job have I
created the wrong business and the best
thing that you can do right now is not
just take a degree because that's the
safe thing to do because that's the easy
way to get a job is to explore what
you're interested in follow your flow
and it may not make sense right now and
that's a scary part right you have no
idea how it's going to work out but
that's the challenge for you to be
courageous enough to follow your flow
and all of these things are going to
come together at some point in your
future to make you an unstoppable force
to make you somebody unique that cannot
just be replaced by somebody else
because all these other people are going
and taking the standard traditional
courses to fill standard traditional
jobs and they're replaceable and they're
boring and they don't like their lives
you are going to be able to create
something where you have the business
experience but then you also bring in
the artistic side and the media side you
could bring that together to be truly
unique and different that's what the
world will reward people who are unique
and different and are following things
that they are excited and passionate
about one of my favorite stories that
relates really well
you with Steve Jobs okay Steve Jobs when
he was in university he found himself
being he's getting disconnected you know
like I'm not I'm not this isn't for me I
need he quit he dropped out of school
and people said what are you nuts like
you have this great opportunity here you
have this great safe job path lined out
for you why would you drop out and you
can look back on his life now and say oh
that was so easy Steve Jobs what a great
decision you know it became a
billionaire entrepreneur built the most
valuable company in the world that was
so smart to do but when he did that he
had no idea what he was going to do he
didn't have that certainty but he had
the courage to know that what he was
doing right now wasn't working and he
had to find something else to do we had
to discover his flow and so he dropped
out of university and then started
dropping in not even getting credit
dropping in on calligraphy classes to
learn about fonts and as an outsider you
may look at I say are you nuts
you left a stable path to have the
stable potential job to leave University
so you can take classes that teach you
about fonts how to draw different
letters are you kidding me and Steve
Jobs at the time too didn't know how
that would all work out he didn't know
how he would ever use this ever in his
life had no idea but he knew that he was
interested by it he was excited by it
he loved the content in that class more
than all of the other classes he was
taking and so we continued learning and
years later when he started Apple
Computer and started building his
computers the Apple products were the
first ones to have different fonts they
were the first ones to bring that in
where all the other computers had the
standard boring basic fonts and that was
one of the key ways that Apple stood out
if you wanted to have beautiful fonts in
your computer for all your programs you
had to go buy an apple and he had no
idea how those dots were lined up but he
trusted that somehow they would
so this is this is the question this is
the thing how courageous are you because
you have to be willing to jump off into
the unknown and trust that by following
a path that excites you following a path
that makes you come alive you're going
to discover yourself and bring together
all these different elements that nobody
has ever done in the history of life
before into a unique person that's going
to be you and when you discover that
person and you bring all those elements
together you're going to be an
unstoppable force because that's who you
truly are you're going to reach your
potential but do you have the courage to
jump off and do it even if you don't
know how it's going to work out yet
that's the question
good luck and believe for those of you
watching you like the video you can
subscribe to the channel by clicking on
the link and I will see you soon